you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftus and i'm denise valdez it's the
monday after the christmas weekend and
while millions of people are stranded at
airports many are waiting in line for
kovid tests local clinics are seeing a
surge after so many people got together
for the holidays victoria saha joins us
live from the site at unlv just as
testing is wrapping up
this drive through testing and vaccines
i closed about a half an hour ago in
fact the last car just drove off right
before we got on air but earlier today
this parking lot was jam packed with
bumper-to-bumper traffic
at a first glance you may think this is
a scene of a kova testing site from 2020
but it's not my guess would be that
everybody has been out with their family
their friends at parties and stuff kind
of worried about exposure joshua lodge
is directing the drive through testing
and vaccine location at unlv he says
they reopened on sunday after being
closed for a week and gave out more
tests than they expected we probably
average around like 200 or so tests at
night depending on the week and the
night it is
and last night we did over a thousand
tests it was just a constant flow of
cars and the rush followed on monday our
team took precautions when speaking with
those waiting i didn't think it is as
serious as it is but it really is ryetta
ellis was the first in line two hours
before the drive-thru clinic opened she
needs a negative covet test to return to
work she says she tried to get a test
earlier but many places were booked
until january 3rd lonnie braythopt also
beat the rush seeing all those cars
behind you what goes through your head
braythupt and her husband did not have
huge holiday gatherings but wanted to
make sure they were covet-free
cautious because you know it can slip up
on anybody
and you just don't know what the hong
kong can be
the director here says it's the second
night in a row where they surpassed 1
000 tests for anyone traveling there is
a clinic at henry reed international
airport where you can get a covet test
but that's going to cost you roughly
around 200 dollars reporting from unlv
tonight victoria zaha live local now